like my kind of my theory of language evolution in general is that like languages grow and then they they like innovate and then they inspire and eventually like people will like migrate from language to language and but then there are other people who will stay and i think that this is kind of like it goes down to some like aspects of human nature where there are people who tend to be more interested in change and people who tend to be more interested in change and people who tend to be more interested in staying where they currently are. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 108 recorded on November 2nd, 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we finished part three of our three-part interview with
比如我对语言演化的一般理论是，语言会发展，然后它们会进行创新，然后它们会启发他人，最终人们会从一种语言迁移到另一种语言，但同时也会有人留下来。我认为这有点类似于人类天性的一些方面：有些人倾向于对改变更感兴趣，而有些人则倾向于保持现状。欢迎收看第 108 期 ADSP 播客，录制于 2022 年 11 月 2 日。我是 Connor，今天我的联合主持是 Bryce，我们完成了对三部分访谈的第三部分，访谈对象是
Jane Lazari-Lusby while talking about the Rust programming language. How much can you say about what's been going on in Rust? I can say that there's like some top level interpersonal breakdowns that caught and some just like structural issues that kind of exacerbated the cause those I would say, where the like the kind of central governance body, the core team became siloed from parts of the project and it caused trust breakdowns across the to be like okay this structure isn't working we need to figure out a new way to do this and solve these problems and so we're working on redesigning and like evolving that top level team and kind of like how we how we go about kind of the the most general governance of the project but like the actual like teams themselves like lang lives everything is they've been functioning very effectively kind of right now i like to say like we're working more like an archipelago than an org tree um so it's like a lot of kind of independent but like you know we work together and we like cross-pollinate
Jane Lazari-Lusby，我们谈论了 Rust 编程语言。对于 Rust 最近发生的事情，你能说多少？我可以说，有一些高层的人际冲突导火索，以及一些加剧了这些问题的结构性问题。我会说，核心治理团队这个中心机构与项目的某些部分脱节了，导致了各个团队之间的信任破裂，进而让人觉得“好吧，这种结构行不通，我们需要找出一种新方法来做到这一点并解决这些问题”，所以我们正在重新设计和演进那个高层团队，以及我们如何着手处理项目最一般的治理方式。但像实际的团队本身——比如语言团队、标准库团队等等——现在它们的运作都非常有效。我喜欢说，我们的运作更像一个群岛而不是一个组织树。所以它有很多独立的个体，你知道的，我们一起工作，我们互相交流
but there's not like a central place for us to easily get together and communicate very often yeah i i think um for for open projects governance models are really hard it's really hard to get things right yeah um you know there's i think often you end up between one of two extremes there's like the benevolent dictator for life model um and then there's the like sort of committee model yeah which which which we call, we termed it here. It's BDFL, Benevolent Dictator for Life. And then there's BTFN, Benevolent Team for Now. Yeah.
但我们没有一个中央地方让我们经常聚在一起沟通。是的，我认为，对于开源项目来说，治理模型真的很难，把事情做好真的很难。你知道，通常你最终会落入两个极端之一：一个是终身仁慈独裁者模型，另一个是某种委员会模型。嗯，这里我们称之为 BDFL，即终身仁慈独裁者（Benevolent Dictator for Life）。然后是 BTFN，即暂时的仁慈团队（Benevolent Team for Now）。
And it's going to catch on if I can remember it and not make the listeners wait. But it's going to catch on. BDFL versus BTFN, which sounds like Rust is closer to. So on the one extreme, you have the benevolent dictator for life. On the other extreme, you have what C++ has, which is where you have some sort of committee model where you
如果我能记住它并且不让听众等太久的话，这肯定会流行起来的。但这绝对会流行起来的。BDFL 对阵 BTFN，听起来 Rust 更接近哪一个。所以在一个极端，你有终身仁慈独裁者。在另一个极端，你有 C++ 那种模型，也就是某种形式的委员会模型，
have a large number of stakeholders, all of whom can hold up progress if they feel that something is being done wrong. And it's hard to be nimble when you have the large set of stakeholders and when you have
其中有大量的利益相关者，如果他们觉得有事情做得不对，所有人都可以阻碍进展。当你有这么大一群利益相关者时，很难做到敏捷；而当你只有
a much smaller set of stakeholders, you can be more nimble, but then you have the risk of that set of stakeholders becoming alienated from the you know the community at large yeah or just having you know a small handful of people making decisions it's hard to strike a balance and i think the best the best processes are the ones that can evolve yeah absolutely like self-repairing organizations are like super important like being able to have feedback loops and like actually being able to
一小群利益相关者时，你可以更敏捷，但随后你就会面临这群利益相关者与广大社区产生隔阂的风险，或者只是由一小撮人做决策。很难找到平衡点，我认为最好的流程是那些能够演进的流程。是的，绝对如此，像自我修复的组织超级重要，能够拥有反馈循环，并且真正能够
self-evaluate and be like is this working like is there something we should change and being able to have feedback loops and actually being able to self-evaluate and be like, is this working? Is there something we should change? And being able to address those problems and being willing to try out new things, I think, is kind of critical components to an effective organization. Yeah. Yeah. And Russ, does the core team, how do people get put onto the core team or uh like how do how do people get put onto like the core team or to like a particular team is it and is there is there like a notion of like a term limit um at you at the top echelons
进行自我评估并思考“这管用吗？我们有什么需要改变的吗？”，并且能够解决这些问题并愿意尝试新事物，我认为这是高效组织的关键组成部分。是的。是的。至于 Rust 的核心团队，人们是如何进入核心团队的？或者说，人们是如何进入核心团队或特定团队的？这其中有没有任期限制的概念？
historically no term limits people are just invited by the team um right now it's basically in flux right now we have an interim governance body, which is the current members of core, the project directors to the board of foundation, and all of the top level team leads, top level teams being teams that do not have a parent team. And so, and those, like all the teams right now, basically work the same way where it's like invite, like you, like if all the teams right now basically work the same way, where it's, like, invite. Like, if the teams recognize your work and think that they want to encourage it, they can invite you to the team.
历史是没有任期限制的，人们只是被团队邀请加入。现在基本上处于变动状态。目前我们有一个临时治理机构，由核心团队的现任成员、基金会董事会的项目董事以及所有顶级团队的负责人组成（顶级团队是指没有父团队的团队）。所以，现在所有的团队基本上都以同样的方式运作，那就是邀请制。比如，如果团队认可你的工作并希望鼓励你，他们就可以邀请你加入团队。
Or you can ask them and be like, hey, I think I've been doing a bunch of work and I'd like to help out. And I think I'd be a good fit. And they can be like, okay, sure, yeah, we agree. But it's not really well documented at the moment. It's, like, one of the things we're working on right now. Like, I can talk about kind of the draft of the RFCc that we have in place of like what we're like looking at what we're looking at is adding a representative body where it's um a it's like a council essentially where you have the you have a representative taken from each of the top
或者你可以主动问他们：“嘿，我觉得我做了很多工作，我想帮忙，我觉得我很合适。”然后他们会说：“好吧，当然，我们同意。”但这目前并没有被很好地记录下来。这是我们现在正在努力的事情之一。我可以谈谈我们目前正在起草的 RFC，我们正在考虑的是增加一个代表机构，它本质上是一个委员会，你从每个顶级
level teams and those those top level teams become sub teams of the council and you have shared membership from those representatives they're on both teams and that acts as the link that helps with communication between the the various teams and um then there will be uh terms not necessarily term limits but there will be like after um i think a year or two um basically like reselection you can like reaffirm i think actually there might be term lines i think we might be talking about like not more than two or three consecutively but um i don't think that's like i think the general vibe is that we want to have like some fresh people coming in like like getting new people experience as well as keeping some of the institutional knowledge and so it can be a double-edged sword.
团队中选出一个代表，这些顶级团队成为委员会的子团队，你拥有来自这些代表的共享成员资格，他们在两个团队中都有席位。这起到了纽带的作用，有助于各个团队之间的沟通。然后会有任期，不一定是任期限制，但会在大约一两年后进行重新选举，你可以重新确认。其实我想可能也会有任期限制，我们可能在讨论连续不超过两三届，但我认为这并不是……我的总体感觉是，我们希望有一些新鲜血液加入，让新人获得经验，同时也保留一些机构知识，所以这可能是一把双刃剑。
You know, the boost foundation has term limits that they rotate. Who's the chair of the, of the, the, what used to be the steering committees now the board, and then they rotate the folks who are on the board. And I think it's both good,
你知道，Boost 基金会是有任期限制的，他们会轮换委员会的主席（以前叫指导委员会，现在叫董事会），然后他们会轮换董事会成员。我认为这既是件好事，
but also like the person who's currently the chair of the board, I think it's both good but also like the person who's currently the chair of the board I think is doing an amazing job and I'll be really sad when somebody else steps in because I think it's really high bar to meet and you know I don't it's not that I would want him to do the job forever it's just that
但同时，比如现任董事会主席，我觉得他做得非常棒，当其他人接替他时我会感到非常难过，因为我认为这是一个很难达到的标准。你知道，倒不是说我希望他永远做这个工作，只是
I would not want him to be limited to you know the one or two year period that had previously been the term. So it's tough to balance because on the other hand, you don't want to have somebody that's been doing the same thing for 10, 20 years. Then I think you start to get stagnation. Yeah, for sure. I did not know about the rust evangelism strike force i did google it and came i did see a lot of very nice images and it has me sort of confused because um
我希望他不要被之前那种一两年的任期所限制。所以这很难平衡，因为从另一方面来看，你也不希望某个人连续 10 年、20 年都在做同一件事。那样的话，我认为就会开始出现停滞。是的，确实如此。我以前不知道 Rust 宣传突击队（Rust Evangelism Strike Force），我确实谷歌了一下，也看到了很多非常漂亮的图片，这让我有点困惑，因为
i mean i think it's hilarious that uh they've got subreddits dedicated to this stuff but it's i mean i'm curious as to like why Rust has this reputation versus every other language that like, like I personally, I don't really consider myself an APL or BQN or J evangelist. But like my, my favorite programming languages are array languages, which are not used really very widely. There are a few companies like Like there's one of those, I'm not sure if you've ever seen those GitHub repos that are like companies that use Haskell. And it's like a list of all the major companies of which there are a few.
我是说，我觉得挺搞笑的，他们竟然有专门讨论这个的 Subreddit，但我是说，我很好奇为什么 Rust 会有这种声誉，而其他语言则没有——比如我个人并不认为自己是一个 APL、BQN 或 J 语言的传道者。但我的，我最喜欢的编程语言是数组语言，它们并没有被非常广泛地使用。有一些公司，就像其中有一家，我不知道你是否见过那些 GitHub 仓库，上面列着使用 Haskell 的公司。这就像是所有主要公司的列表，虽然大公司只有寥寥几家。
All three companies? No, like there's like hundreds that use Haskell. Like even GitHub and Facebook. He loves array languages so much that he won't even let me troll about them. No, well, no, you were trolling about Haskell right there. Oh, yeah, fair, fair. But there's a similar repo for array languages that has, you know,
全部三家公司？不，比如有几百家公司在使用 Haskell。甚至连 GitHub 和 Facebook 都在用。他太喜欢数组语言了，甚至都不让我拿它们开玩笑。不，好吧，你刚才明明是在拿 Haskell 开玩笑。哦，对，也是，也是。但数组语言也有类似的仓库，里面有，
I don't know if it's 100 companies on there, but, you know, there's probably more than 100 companies out in the world that are making use of these. But I don't really consider myself an evangelist, but I've definitely given a ton of talks that it's like, basically like preaching, you know, what you can learn from going to this different paradigm that will change the way you think about solving problems. It's not necessarily so that you should go write your code, you know, your production code in this language, but it's like, going to Haskell or going to, you know, array language or going to a Lisp, you're going to learn new things. And even if it's like going to Haskell or going to, you know, array language or going to a list. You're going to learn new things.
我不知道上面有没有 100 家公司，但你知道，世界上可能不止 100 家公司在使用这些语言。但我并不认为自己是一个传道者，不过我确实做过大量的演讲，基本上就像是在布道，你知道的，你可以从接触这种不同的范式中学到什么，这会改变你思考解决问题的方式。这不一定是为了让你用这种语言去编写代码，你知道的，你的生产代码，而是说，接触 Haskell 或接触，你知道的，数组语言，或者接触 Lisp，你会学到新的东西。即使只是接触 Haskell 或接触数组语言，或者接触 Lisp，你也将会学到新的东西。
And even if it's just about the tools, like Haskell, I learned about Hoogle, which I'm not sure if you're familiar. I learned that Rust has Roogle. Yeah, which is frigging amazing. Like Hoogle is definitely, I'm not sure if it's top three, but definitely top five coolest things I've ever discovered in terms of tools or IDE functionality. We should maybe explain what this is for the listener who may be unaware.
而且即使只是关于工具本身，比如 Haskell，我了解到了 Hoogle，我不知道你是否熟悉。我发现 Rust 也有 Roogle。是的，这简直太棒了。Hoogle 绝对是，我不知道算不算前三，但绝对是我发现过的最酷的工具或 IDE 功能前五名。我们或许应该向可能不知道这一点的听众解释一下这是什么。
Yeah, very quickly. I mean, it's a little bit different because Haskell has type signatures and a really, really strong type inference engine. So to try and think about something like this in C++ or even Rust, it's a little bit trickier. But I guess for Rust, because they come from ML background, it's easier. But basically, you can ask for every single function that gives you a list of integers, given a list of integers, returns you a list of integers,
好的，非常快地解释一下。我是说，它有点不同，因为 Haskell 有类型签名和非常非常强大的类型推导引擎。所以在 C++ 甚至 Rust 中去思考类似的东西会稍微棘手一些。但我想对于 Rust 来说，因为它们来自 ML 背景，所以会更容易。不过基本上，你可以查询每一个函数：给你一个整数列表，给定一个整数列表，它会返回给你一个整数列表，
such as reverse or shuffle or something like that. And if you wanted to find every function that takes a list of integers, a single integer, and then returns you a list of integers, it'd give you the functions like that. And if you wanted to find every function that takes a list of integers, a single integer, and then returns you a list of integers, it'd give you the functions like, uh, take and drop or, you know,
比如 reverse（反转）或 shuffle（洗牌）之类的。如果你想找到每一个接收一个整数列表、一个单独整数，然后返回一个整数列表的函数，它就会把这样的函数列出来。如果你想找到每一个接收一个整数列表、一个单独整数，然后返回一个整数列表的函数，它就会把像……这样的函数列出来，比如
whatever your language is. I think Russ calls them take and skip. Um, but, uh, it's, it's phenomenal. And there's a few other features,
take 和 drop，或者不管你的语言叫什么。我想 Rust 叫它们 take 和 skip。但是，这真的是太棒了。还有其他一些特性，
um, or tools, whatever you want to call them. Uh, and so the point is, is like, you go to these different languages, you learn a lot of awesome things.
或者说工具，随便你怎么称呼它们。所以重点是，你去接触这些不同的语言，你会学到很多很棒的东西。
And why is it that Russ for some reason has a repeat like got this whole subreddit thing of like trying to sell the language too hard because when really a lot of the times when i'm listening to an elixir podcast or a python podcast they're really doing the same thing you know where they're like you know python 3.11 just came out and it's now 60 faster unless if you're using numpy in which case it's zero percent faster because that's actually just calling c++ code um and and they're all you know promoting their language so do you know why like rusk got because it seems like every language does that to a certain extent i definitely don't have like a clear answer but i can i can like make some guesses i think on at one level the rust community
为什么 Rust 莫名其妙地会有这种声誉——搞出了整个 subreddit 来拼命推销这门语言？因为很多时候，当我听 Elixir 播客或 Python 播客时，他们其实也在做同样的事情，你知道的，他们会说：“Python 3.11 刚刚发布，现在速度提高了 60%——除非你在用 Numpy，这种情况下速度提升就是 0%，因为那其实只是在调用 C++ 代码。”而且他们也都在，你知道的，推广自己的语言。所以你知道为什么 Rust 会变成这样吗？因为似乎每种语言在某种程度上都会这么做。我肯定没有一个清晰的答案，但我可以做出一些猜测。我认为在某种程度上，Rust 社区
has like leaned into it and like has like they've participated in the meme and have perpetuated and amplified it to a degree i think another element of it is actually just like the context from what you're viewing it from i'm not sure that rust has really this same um like reputation amongst other language communities as much as it is like more in c++ and c um i'm not positive on this personally like people from other communities can come like fact check that um but my guess is that like like my kind of my theory of language evolution in general is that like languages grow and they like innovate and then they inspire. And eventually like people will like migrate from language to language. And but then there are other people who will stay.
顺应了这种趋势，参与了这种梗文化，并在某种程度上将其延续和放大了。我认为另一个因素其实只是你观察它的上下文。我不确定 Rust 在其他语言社区中是否有同样的这种声誉，它更多是在 C++ 和 C 语言圈子里。对此我本人并不是百分之百确定，来自其他社区的人可以来事实核查一下。但我的猜测是——我关于语言演化的一般理论是，语言会发展，它们会创新，然后它们会启发他人。最终人们会从一种语言迁移到另一种语言。但同时也会有人留下来。
And I think that this is kind of like it goes down to some like aspects of human nature where there are people who tend to be more interested in change and people who tend to be more interested in staying where they currently are. And so when you see like right now, C++ and I think also Haskell in a sense, I think was on the other side of this when it comes to Rust, where you get these communities that where they're doing a bunch of innovation and then a new language comes along that's doing a bunch of new things and all the people who were like chafing under the existing system or were interested in trying something new a lot of those people go and join the new community and you get left with a lot of the people who were on the more conservative happy with the current side happy with staying where they currently are and so i think that that kind
我认为这有点类似于人类天性的某些方面：有些人倾向于对改变更感兴趣，而有些人则倾向于保持现状。所以你会看到，现在 C++（以及某种程度上的 Haskell，当它面对 Rust 时我觉得也在另一边）会吸引这样一些社区：他们在进行大量创新，然后一门能做很多新事情的新语言出现了，所有那些在现有系统下感到憋屈或者对尝试新事物感兴趣的人，他们中的许多人都会加入新社区，而留下的往往是那些更保守、对现状满意、倾向于保持现状的人。所以我觉得这在很大程度上扭曲了反应，随着时间的推移，你会发现那些对提出的替代方案不感兴趣的人的浓度越来越高。所以从 C++ 的角度来看，你会看到很多这种批评，比如“这些人把东西硬塞给我们”之类的话，因为他们看到自己的朋友离开了，这其实是可以理解的。我在想 Kotlin 社区是否存在类似的现象——我花在 JVM 语言上的时间非常少。我认为这是普遍存在的，对吧？就像是这样吗？我不确定 Kotlin 是否有一个 Kotlin……哦，是的。我不确定有没有。
of skews the the reaction a lot where like as time goes on you get kind of more of a concentration of people who are are like not excited about the alternatives that are being presented and so like from the c++ perspective you see a lot of this kind of criticism of like these people are like shoving things down our throat and all this stuff because like they see their friends leaving it's like it's understandable i wonder if there's a similar phenomenon that exists in like the kotlin community like i don't i have spent very little time in jvm languages i think it's universal yeah like is it the same like i'm not sure if Kotlin has a Kotlin. Oh, yeah. I'm not sure about that. Evangelism Strikeforce, like, subreddit kind of thing.
“宣传突击队”那样的 Subreddit。但我很好奇其中是否存在很多类似的摩擦——我不会称之为敌意，但那是这两个社区之间的摩擦，因为 Kotlin 明显拥有更棒的代码补全功能。类似于 Carbon 的推广方式，谷歌那些从事这项工作的人曾在 Google I.O. 演讲中展示过：有 50 行 Java 代码试图实现某种不可变类，然后你点击一个按钮，砰的一下，它就缩减到了大约 3 行在后台自动生成所有这些代码的 Kotlin。这难道不美妙吗？我很好奇，在那些认为“Java 可以拥有所有这些好东西，我们为什么要扔掉所有这些技术、技术债务或投资”阵营的人，和那些看到 Kotlin 并坚决投身其中去从事新语言工作的人之间，是否存在着某种类似摩擦的东西。
But I wonder if there's a lot of the same, I wouldn't call it animosity, but, like, friction between those two communities where Kotlin is clearly, nicer code completion to the point where, similar to how Carbon's being promoted, the folks at Google that are working on it, that you can take some existing Java code, and they've shown these in Google I.O. talks. And it's like 50 lines of Java trying to do some immutable class thing and then you click a button and poof it's like down to like three lines of kotlin that like has all that stuff auto-generated behind the scenes how beautiful is that um and i wonder if there's a little bit of the same kind of friction of folks that are in the camp of like java can have all these nice things why would we throw away all this tech, you know, all this, you know, technology, technological debt or, you know, investment, or if you want to use a nicer term than like to go and work on a new language versus the folks that saw Kotlin and then absolutely.
绝对是的。而且我认为谷歌，他们将其提升为 Android 应用开发的黄金语言，至少是这样。至少我从道听途说中听到的就是这样。我不在谷歌工作，但我记得自我密切关注 Google I.O. 活动以来，从 2018 年左右的一次 Google I.O. 到 2019 年发生了一个转变，当时的态度是：“如果你想用，这里有对 Kotlin 的支持。”然后到了第二年的活动上，就变成了 Kotlin 优先。我对这些社区没有什么深入了解，但我
And I think Google is like, they promoted it to their kind of golden language for Android app development, at least, at least. At least that's what I've heard from like, you know, arm's length distance or something like that. I don't work at Google, but I recall when I was following Google I.O. events closely that there was a shift from one Google I.O. in 2018 or something to 19, where it was like, you know, here's a support for Kotlin if you want it. And then it was like Kotlin first at uh at like the next year's one i i have no insight into those communities but i
会非常好奇想要了解。所以如果任何观众有任何见解，那将非常有趣。我们的观众相当聪明，他们可能真的知道。实际上，我相当确凿地认为，我们的听众——不是观众，是听众，不过我想我们的……我相当确凿地认为，我们的听众比我们要聪明得多。因为我们有过相当多的节目，里面全是听众来纠正我们的错误。确实如此，对吧？每隔一段时间，我们就会有一个听众兼好朋友 Ben Dean，他会给我发私信，说：“好吧，
would be very curious to know so if any of the viewers have any any insight that would be very interesting our viewers are pretty smart they might know actually i'm i'm fairly certain that our our uh our listener or listeners not viewers listeners but i guess our uh i'm pretty certain that our listeners are a good bit smarter than us like we we we have had a fair number of episodes that have just been uh listeners correcting us about things and that's true yeah whenever every once in a while we have a listener and a good friend bandine who'll like dm me and he's true yeah whenever every once in a while we have a listener and a good friend ben dean who'll like dm me he's like all right i've i have a long enough list from the last like 12 episodes uh you can either address these you know just in line or you can
过去大概 12 期节目里我列了一张足够长的清单，你要么在节目里直接回应这些问题，要么把我请上节目，我当面把它们提出来。”这听起来更像是一个威胁。对于个人想要智胜一个群体来说，我认为这要追溯到 BDFL 对阵委员会（暂时的仁慈团队）。依赖群体的智慧能从长远获得更好的结果，哪怕是以牺牲速度为代价。这也是为什么总会有观众比你们知道得更多，因为听众基数要大得多。我是说，既然我现在非官方地转投 Rust，我感觉自己不需要知道那么多东西了，你知道的，就……好吧，编译器、Clippy，所有这些都会……你知道的，我只需要稍微更好地理解内存模型就行了，因为我偶尔还是会在那上面栽跟头。你知道，哦对了，我得克隆（clone）一下。我得复制（copy）一下。
have me on and i will bring them up in person i think it sounds more like a threat it's for like an individual to outsmart a group I think that's you know it goes back to the BDFL versus committee the dental committee for now um it's like the relying on group wisdom gets you the the better outcomes long term even at the cost of speed so and that's the same reason you're gonna have viewers who always know more than you because there's so many more listeners listeners i mean now that i'm unofficially switching to rust i just i feel like i don't need to know stuff you know it's just well the compiler clippy all these things will just uh you know i just got to figure out the memory model a little bit better because i still trip up up up on that every once in a while. You know, oh, right, I got to clone something. I got to copy something.
这其实回到了当 Bryce 询问它如何运作时的特征（trait）系统。我还没有实现过，所谓——其实我不知道它们叫什么。也许它们就是特征。但就像当你写 `impl` 尖括号，你知道的，你的泛型类型 `T`，冒号，然后是一堆东西。那些全都是特征。
And that's actually going back to the trait system when Bryce was asking how it works. I have not implemented, quote unquote, I actually don't know what they're called. Maybe they're traits. But it's like when you go impl bracket, impl angle bracket, you know, your generic type T, colon, and then a list of stuff. Those are all traits those are traits or is there another word those are trait bounds like inside the yeah the the angle brackets is for generic parameters and anything you put after a colon is a is a bound there's like three different ways to specify bounds it's not my favorite
那些是特征，还是有别的什么词？那些是特征约束（trait bounds）。比如在尖括号内部用于泛型参数，而你在冒号后面放的任何东西都是一个约束。指定约束有大约三种不同的语法，这不是我最喜欢的语言部分，因为语法有点重复，但你知道的，能用就行。所以那些就是约束。
part of the language how there's like duplication of syntax there but you know you get what you get yeah so those are balanced yeah so those like i haven't done anything with them other than like try to do something with like a generic trait and then they're like oh you know you can't do that it needs to be orderable or you know or something so i have a bunch of stood colon colon compare colon colon partial order and then hash hash compare eek clone clone marker copy compare or i don't know any of that stuff but uh the compiler was just like well if you want to do this thing if you want to convert stuff into a hash set or something you need this and then they're like would you like to add it and i'm like i mean that sounds like a reasonable thing that i would like to do in order to get this
所以我除了尝试用泛型特征做点什么之外，没有用它们做过任何其他事情。然后他们就会说：“哦，你知道的，你不能那样做，它需要是有序的（orderable）或者诸如此类。”所以我就有一堆 `std::cmp::PartialOrder`，还有 `Hash`、`Eq`、`Clone`、`Copy`、`Marker`，诸如此类的东西。其实我根本不懂这些，但编译器就会说：“好吧，如果你想做这件事，如果你想把东西转成哈希集合（hash set）或别的什么，你需要这个。”然后他们就会问：“你想添加它吗？”我就想：“嗯，听起来为了让这段代码跑通，我确实需要做这件事。”然后我就直接复制粘贴。所以这就是问题所在，就像我们之前讨论的听众比我们聪明一样，我不再觉得自己在用这门语言编程时必须表现得那么聪明了。而在过去，你知道的，我得在 C++ 里背诵那些诸如“如果你没有析构函数，那么你需要这个，巴拉巴拉”的 1、3、5、6、7、8、9 条规则表格。而现在，在 C++ 里如果你没有析构函数就需要这个、那个……而现在我觉得，我不在乎 Rust 里有没有这东西，因为显然我不需要知道它。编译器会直接告诉我。
code to work and then i just you know copy paste. And so that's the thing is like, I don't know, it's like, we're talking about our listeners being smarter than us. It's like, I no longer feel like I actually have to be that smart to program in this language. Whereas like, you know, previously, I was memorizing tables of, you know, the 1356789 rule in C++ of if you don't have a destructor, then you need this, blah, blah, blah. And now it, 8, 9 rule in C++ of if you don't have a destructor, then you need this, blah, blah, blah. And now it's like, well, I don't care if that exists in Rust because apparently I don't need to know it. The compiler will just tell me.
最终你会达到那种境界，比如你精通了所有这些东西，然后你就会去从事实际的新功能开发，或者做你正在做的任何软件开发。你会成为某个相关领域无人知晓的专家，并做出一些很酷的贡献。所以……是的，也许这就是为什么——也许这就是为什么 Rust 会有现在的声誉，因为在新手体验上投入了如此之多的精力，以至于你最后会觉得自己像个超级英雄，然后你就会想要去告诉别人：
Eventually you'll get there where you're like, you know, all that stuff. And then you're going to be working on actual new features or doing whatever software development you're doing. You're going to be an expert on something that's gonna be relevant that no one else knows about if you'll make some cool contributions, so Yeah, maybe that's why maybe that's why they rust has the reputation it does so much it seems has been invested into the beginner experience that You don't like you just end up feeling like a superhero and then like you want to go and tell people
“天哪，你知道吗，这真的太棒了。”无论如何，我们已经到了之前说的时间，我大概必须停下来了，因为我明天和后天都要赶飞机，总而言之……好吧，在最后这一两分钟里，有什么你想宣传或提及、但我们还没聊到的、值得宣传或提及或提出的话题吗？不，你可别提你的火车了……我们在聊培训呢！我们是在聊培训。不，我们这是 Jane 的时间。你想当我的新搭档吗，Jane？我不介意多参加几次 Rust 的节目，但我不太确定能否承诺长期做联合主持，不过作为嘉宾绝对非常有趣。
Oh my goodness, like, you know, this is this is so great. and uh anyways we're at the time that we said i probably do have to uh stop because i've got to be on a plane tomorrow and the day after and then just in general okay is there any in our last one two minutes here is there anything you want to plug or mention that we haven't talked about that is worth plugging or mentioning or bringing up and no you're not telling your shin we're talking about the training we're talking about the training no we're we're giving this is jane's time uh you want to be you want to be my new co-host jane i wouldn't mind joining more of these rust episodes i'm not sure about committing to co-hosting but being a guest has definitely been very fun um the as for plugs um there is a one project of mine that i wouldn't mind plugging which is awesome rust mentors so there's like a list
至于宣传，我有一个项目不介意宣传一下，那就是 Awesome Rust Mentors（Rust 优秀导师）。那里基本上列出了各种各样非常可爱的、经验丰富并已经使用该语言一段时间的 Rust 开发者，
of just basically like all sorts of lovely rustations that are quite experienced and have been using the language for a while and And basically like the languages they speak, time zones they're in, I think. Definitely the topics of interest and contact info. And I would highly recommend anyone who is like kind of trying to navigate the open source Rust or like trying to, wants to get deeper into it and wants someone to talk to,
列出了他们说的语言、他们所在的时区，我想还有他们感兴趣的主题和联系方式。我强烈建议任何试图摸索开源 Rust、或者想更深入了解它并希望找人交流、又没有感觉聊得来的 Rust 熟人的人，去看看那个名单，交个朋友，然后快速提升自己。说实话，难怪 Rust 会有这种名声。它实在是太友好了。Bryce，C++ 有哪怕一点点接近这个的东西吗？我想没有。
doesn't have Rust people they already feel comfortable talking to, you can check out that list and make a friend and start getting better real quick. I mean, honestly, no wonder Rust has this reputation. It's just too nice. Bryce, does C++ have anything even remotely close to this? I don't think so. No.
最接近的是什么？就像把一条推文发到 Twitter 星球上？你可能通过这种方式得到答案。如果你能加入 C++ 委员会，然后你就可以给邮件列表发邮件。诸如此类。我是说，以前有，我不知道。有一些地方比如 Discord 还不错，但并没有一个官方的好地方让我们
What's the closest thing? Just like shooting a tweet off into like the Twittersphere? Like you probably will get answers that way. If you could join the C++ committee, then you could send an email to the reflector. Something like that. I mean, there used to be, I don't know. There are places they include discords nice but there's um there's not like an official place that's that's good for us
这在其他语言中存在吗？我想我记得实际上在你的 Twitter 简介里看到过这个，但我记不得……我觉得我看到过有人谈论在他们自己的语言社区中启动类似的项目。我不知道目前是否有哪个社区特别活跃。我能想到的最接近的是桥梁（bridges），我知道 Clojure 和 Ruby 是两个拥有被称为 Ruby Bridges（Ruby 桥）和 Clojure Bridges 的社区。我其实从来没参加过任何一个，所以我基本上是凭空捏造的，但我认为它们有点像虚拟或面对面的聚会加新手周末，其设计初衷就是为了吸引那些想要开始学习编程或开始学习 Ruby 或 Clojure 的人。并且重点在于，
does this exist in other languages i don't think i've i think i recall actually seeing this in your twitter bio but i had not um i don't recall who i feel like i've seen people talk about starting it in their own language communities i don't know if there's any that are like particularly active at the moment the closest thing i can think of is bridges like i know closure and ruby are two communities that had things called ruby bridges i think and closure bridges which were like i've actually never been to any so i'm sort of just making this up, but I think there were like sort of either virtual or in-person meetups slash like beginner weekends where it was intentionally designed to sort of people that wanted to either start learning programming or to start learning Ruby or Closure. And with an emphasis on, you know,
真正确保他们撒下大网以吸引多元化的人群，并且真正专注于包容性并让人感到受欢迎——但这绝对、绝对和我们拥有的不一样。我们也有一个 Rust 桥，某种程度上。它就像是一个由分会等组成的分布式组织，我认为做的是同样的事情。它是基于 Ruby Bridge 的，但这更多是一种自治的、只是一个网站的形式，人们只需与之互动，就能拉取并寻找可以交流的人，而无需真正注册任何东西
really making sure that they were casting a wide net to get a diverse group of people and that we're like really focused on inclusivity and like making people feel welcome but that's definitely that's definitely not the same as we have a rust bridge as well sort of it's like a kind of distributed organization of like like chapters and stuff that do i think the same thing it's based on roby bridge but this is more this is more of like a kind of autonomous just it's just a website and people just interact with it and are able to pull and like find people This is more of like a kind of autonomous, it's just a website and people just interact with it and are able to pull and find people to talk to without having to really sign up for anything
或进行任何那么正式的操作。太棒了。好吧，我们一定会把链接留在节目简介里，供感兴趣的人查阅。希望如此。我们将拭目以待这期节目效果如何。等等，我现在可以聊我的火车应用了吗？等等，这要花多长时间？花不了多长时间。
or anything so formal. Awesome. Well, we will definitely leave a link in the show notes for folks that are interested, hopefully. We will see how well this episode came out. Wait, can I talk about my train app now? Wait, how long is this going to take? It's not going to take long.
我只是想念给你听。好吧，Jane，坚持住。如果你需要悄悄地、默默地退出的的话……所以，我爱日本，但有时日本政府的一个应用程序或网站只会让我感到极度焦虑。所以，最终，日本的新干线（子弹头列车）现在有了一种途径，你可以……在网上买票了。这就像是一个新事物，列车非常先进，总是准点，如果它们哪怕晚点
I'm just going to read you. All right, Jane, hang in there. If you need to drop off secretly, silently. So I love Japan, but sometimes there's like an app or a website from the Japanese government that just causes me great anxiety and so so finally the uh the japanese bullet trains the shinkansen they now have a a way where you can um uh buy tickets online um this is like a new thing like very advanced trains they're always on time if they're like if they're like
15 秒，他们就会道歉。它们总是准点，如果它们晚点 15 秒，他们就会道歉。它们总是准点，但它们最近才有了一个网站，现在它们甚至有了一个应用程序。没有双重身份验证，密码必须在 4 到 8 个字符之间。什么？不记住密码，或者说……最大 8 位。不记住密码，不支持生物识别，每 5 分钟登出一次。所以你每 5 分钟就需要重新输入一次密码。请告诉我它不保存支付信息。
15 seconds late they apologize um they're always on time if they're like if they're like 15 seconds late they apologize um they're always on time but like they only had a website recently and now now they have an app too um no two-factor authentication passwords have to be between four and eight characters what it does not remember the password or yeah eight max doesn't remember the password doesn't have any support for biometrics, logs you out after five minutes. So you need to reenter your password every five minutes. Please tell me it doesn't save payment info.
它存储了你的信用卡凭证，并且在不需要任何额外授权（比如你的 CVV 码）的情况下进行购买。而且你不能在晚上 11 点半到早上 5 点半之间进行购买。我简直得给自己设置一个提醒：当我从日本回来时，一定要去这个应用程序里删除我的支付信息，以防它不可避免地被黑客攻击。这真的让我很难过。其实还算有点意思，虽然它的 UI 看起来像 90 年代的，这倒是我对几乎所有政府网站的预期，但它的 UI 并没有我想象的那么糟，只是它实在太不安全了，让我难过。可不是嘛。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。
It stores your credit card credentials and makes purchases without requiring any additional authorization like your CVV code. And you cannot make purchases between 11.30 pm and 5 30 a.m it's just like i had to set a reminder to myself that like when i get back from japan go and delete my payment information from this app for when it is inevitably hacked it just makes me very sad that was kind of worth it actually I thought it was it has a UI from like the 90s which is sort of what I expect from
本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
pretty much any government website but like the UI isn't as bad as I'd thought but it's just so insecure makes me sad. Damn. Yeah. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
几乎所有的政府网站，虽然用户界面没我想象的那么糟，但安全性太差了，真让人难过。该死。是的。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。